Hi guys.
Dr. Berg here.
In this video, we're going to talk about five
health habits for bloating and belly fat.
So take note.
Number one, avoid grazing.
What does that mean?
It means all the snacking between the meals
has to go.
Why?
Because every time you eat, you trigger a
hormone called insulin.
Insulin creates inflammation in your colon.
It just makes things swell up.
What you want to do is to three meals a deal
only and if you can even two meals a day eventually,
because what will happen that third meal will
be your body eating the belly fat because
we want it to burn fat.
Insulin is a switch.
If insulin is low, you won't have any bloating
at all in your stomach.
If insulin is high, you'll feel bloated.
So, avoid grazing.
Number two, avoid certain veggies.
Now, for me, I can't eat broccoli.
I like broccoli, but it bloats me.
Everyone's different.
You might get bloated from kale.
You might get bloated from cabbage.
So, whatever vegetable that bloats you, avoid
it because even though it's healthy, you don't
want anything to bloat you.
Number three, avoid grains and sugar.
Now, this is the obvious one.
You probably already know this.
The gluten, the protein in grains is called
gluten, will really create inflammation in
your colon.
It's the number one source of IBS, irritable
bowel syndrome, diverticulitis, Crohn's and
all these digestive issues.
You want to avoid that.
Not to mention the grains itself because grains
turn into sugar, which increases, you got
it, insulin.
Also, sugar, sugar creates a spike in insulin
that creates swelling of the belly, especially
if you combine it with protein or even fat.
So, sugar is not good at all and if you combine
it, you get a worse effect.
So, avoid grains and all sugars.
Number four, avoid over eating.
Another obvious one, but a lot of times if
you're just in a certain mode, especially
at a restaurant, you can just really down
some food, or a social event.
You just keep eating and eating and eating,
or watching TV, you keep eating, eating, eating.
So, I recommend that you really be conscious
about what you're eating and don't stuff yourself
because it's going to take a long time to
digest that food.
Number five, eating when you are not hungry.
There's this whole philosophy that you have
to always eat a breakfast.
I use to be the guy pushing that.
Or you have to eat through the day six small
meals, even if you're not hungry because it
will stimulate your metabolism.
No, no, no, no.
When you're not hungry, do not eat.
Why?
Because your body is burning fat.
If you add food, the food is probably not
digested from the last meal, it's going to
sit there and cause more bloating.
So, only eat when you are hungry.
So, I hoped this helped.
Go ahead and apply this and give me some comments
below.